[Music]
we continue to celebrate hispanic
heritage month and it turns out that the
valley is the center of mariachi music
education yes and guess who found that
out brian loftus he found two ccsd
schools with thriving mariachi programs
[Music]
the heart of mariachi musical education
is right here in our valley so here in
las vegas we we're kind of like the
epicenter for mariachi education in the
u.s over 6 000 students in 40 schools
take mariachi as an elective in ccsd
it's traditional
music education we're just using
mariachi as a vehicle it's the largest
in the nation the largest in the nation
and a point of great pride in bringing
traditional hispanic culture to
thousands to spread the mariachi word
two schools with thriving programs
fremont middle school
and del sol academy the performing arts
[Music]
it feels good because we're expressing
expressing our culture
through songs and music and how we play
but more of excitement like showing
tradition and
you know being up there and singing
practicing performing competing
succeeding when we have events
i mean we literally pack the house
once you get on stage it's like
like you have all these people looking
at you the performances are amazing like
you feel so good on stage and i think
it's one of the most amazing things that
i get to be on stage and just have a
great time mariachi reaches the
community creating a connection when
they see that that the school district
validates the music from their home
country it kind of like i think it
validates them the support that they
have and they want to motivate us as
students to keep going
connect with the music connect with the
heritage the culture everything these 6
000 las vegas students will continue to
share the familiar joyous and
sentimental sounds of traditional
mariachi music
we all put our hard work into it and
like once you get the song down and you
know everyone
harmonizes it sounds good i love it i
love hearing it i love seeing the
passion that they grow for it